the one that I was involved in was a
distribution state so the fact is the
ex-wife actually didn't fulfill the
factors
um so that actually what gained like
that worked in favor of my client what
does fulfill the factors mean so the
statutory factors he was in the state of
Colorado and in the state of Colorado
you have statutory factor for example
yeah I don't know if how people are
going to take this but it is the factors
for example if she wants 50 percent
she will basically get whatever
percentage from the assets it became
like compensate compensating for her
contribution to the marriage if she took
care of children there's a percentage
gave up things like home making
as opposed to his 50 doesn't make sense
yeah